welcome everyone to the lecture tonight
and we're going to talk about end games
and many different topics we're not
going to just focus on one particular
end game positions so we're going to
start out by doing some Indian
fortresses which is a very important
thing for you to know what is a fortress
anybody familiar with the fortress and
maybe you can explain what is the
fortress actually a fortress is where
basically have material advantage but
you know you can't really you have a
material advantage but your opponent
somehow you cannot break through so like
in this position black this is a
position where it cannot be won so black
is a fortress here even though he's down
a knight and upon but white cannot
really make progress
so positions like that where the one
player is way behind the material but
somehow he can manage to hold the
position that's a fortress and in
fortress position so here is we have one
example here if you look at the position
it seems like it's white should be
winning this clearly because he's got a
extra night and a pawn on a 7 trunk and
you know it's not even he has a wrong
color Bishop we're going to talk about
the wrong color bishop also today but
like if we had a dark square bishop here
instead of a knight that would have been
the wrong color
Bishop endgame but here the the problem
here for white is he can't really move
this knight anywhere without dropping
this a7 pawn and if you drop the a7 pawn
you're not going to win the game so you
can really win it within a nick so and
the problem is that every time you try
to get closer it's a stalemate so
imagine in a position like this if
you're trying to win this position this
is still fine but you're white and you
just make one careless move you know one
careless move in a completely winning
position and guess what you're not
winning this game because it's going to
be a fortress position where you cannot
break
so that's why in this position you don't
want to play a seven in this position
the winning plan is king to be six and
now his king will go to be eight and you
push up on and he comes here you
checkmate with a knight okay so be very
careful when you have a position like
this when you have a corner pawn the
fortresses can happen in this kind of
positions with the knight in a pawn but
each player has Kings only if you have a
corner pump okay the side pawn like a or
H pawn so be very careful and don't just
start just pushing the pawn in a
position like this it's also would be
there are careless in a position like
this for example you reach a position
like this and so let's say you you are
in a position like this and you're just
thinking about pushing the pawn for now
it's okay you push but you don't want to
just just continuously push it here you
make one mistake it's going to be a draw
here you push the pawn he attacks you
upon now you cannot really properly
protect it 97 I just take it so push it
goes here same exact position you cannot
win this position anymore because if you
bring the King he just goes to the
corner you bring your king he just comes
back you come up he goes there this
squares you can never go to this course
you go to is just going to be a
stalemate so you can't really do
anything so that's that's the problem
here okay
and if Kings b6 King goes now it's still
made so be very careful when you have a
knight in extra pawn the corner pawn be
very accurate when you're advancing the
pawn because if you make a mistake there
is a way for your point to get a
fortress position like this where you
cannot really break through
okay so fortress 1 next position is it
clear for everybody how we win this
position you win this by by bringing
your king and accurately pushing the
pawn okay before you push the pawn on a
7th rank make sure your King is really
doing b6 one more time demonstration
okay for you to get
more confidence when you do this
positions so you push the pond he goes
back you just go here you get your King
don't don't push the pond too much here
and you just wait
it goes back your King comes to the
sixth ring remember Kings on the sixth
okay and here again this would be a draw
so you bring your knight closer because
you want to make sure when you play a
seven check the next idea it's a mate
okay like check check see if you had
pushed this pawn again careless move
draw equals now it's still made position
if you move away with a king he takes
your pawn and your knight is not in the
ability to just go here and checkmate so
that's why you have to be very careful
okay converting this kind of Indians
next position I have is this position so
here another position that feels like
you know we have the right call a bishop
because the queening square is the color
of the bishop so this the right color
but surprisingly a position like this
this is also fortress here there is no
way for white to win this because again
same the case you know the pawn is too
advanced and that square cannot be used
for the King to go to so for example we
try to get closer of course you can win
this game if your opponent is playing a
bad move like here you will come here
and checkmate but if you go skiing c8
unfortunately you don't have a way of
making progress here because you go
check if he goes away you go King b7 so
it goes here you try to close the King
and try to box them into checkmate but
it problems if it goes here you can go
here and here the King is boxed in and
if you go check he just comes back so
there's no way for you in order for you
to win this position you need to win the
pawn
but since you cannot win the pond here
you can't really win so memorize this
endgame because you know there will be
some chances for you to you will get
this position so you know that if you're
black this is a draw if you're white you
have to be careful don't get a pawn on a
six so I'm going to push this change the
position a little bit and push the pawn
on a six here this is a easily one
position here how what is the big
difference that you notice here with the
pawn on e5 and the pawn on a 6 c1 the
square changes the character of the
whole position with the idea King to a 6
now see we have the squares this squares
cannot be used so it has to move away
you pick it up
the push
now you can use this idea for example if
you want to push up on a king away from
your king it's a good idea to remember
you put the bishop between your king and
his king it could be used in a different
indian positions also if you want his
king to go away further so you put your
bishop
between you know your king and his king
and then if the King moves away then you
simply go here a seven eight okay
so easily winning position if the pawn
is on a five but if it's already on a
six so you play this move and there is
really no way for you to make progress
here you can only win this position if
your opponent plays a huge blunder King
goes to the corner then you can make
them I don't need that there is no way
for you to really force the matters here
so like you go here he goes here you go
here he goes to the corner you can't
really force him to do anything okay so
we tend with an intent to usually
advance our pounds and you know gaining
space and with the hope that one day we
will win the pawn on b7 but we also have
to be careful sometimes because later on
in the endgame like in this example you
reach this position and you can really
break through here as well because you
don't have access a way to access the
pawn on b7 here so here let's try to win
this so we try to walk in ecigs
he goes here if king f7 you go King D
seven if King goes to c8 he goes King g7
now you go here
okay here
right we see we can't really come even
here that's still made already
we should be so you have we can well now
if it plays the wrong move then you win
if it goes to e8 you win because you
just go here
and then you just come here to pick up
the pawn but the problem is he is going
to stay with his pawn you can't you can
get really close but every time you do
this or this my king is simply going to
be locked in in a corner and it's just
not going to work so that's why it's
it's a problem okay so this is another
example where a pawn is on a sixth rank
and there is no way really to get closer
here to the to the pawn on let b7 to win
this game okay next position what do you
think of the following position okay do
you think this could be a fortress or
white can eventually break through here
and win
you think white can break through or
this is still going to be a job but if
you say you need to you're going to win
this you need to come up with a plan so
we need a plan here so we can see need a
plan and I'm not saying there is a
winning plan here I'm just trying to see
you have this position I mean and you're
going to feel like I've got a I've got
to win this somehow I must have a plan
here and what's the plan let's say we
move the Kings is AHA oh yeah
it's it's an idea it's an idea but I'm
not sure if that does anything like like
oh here
King h7
I'm happy with the drawers I'm happy
with the draw here so I need a plan you
have a win
okay let's see you win okay okay lets me
block that then so we need a way to
break through here yeah
so he's just going to go here here here
here basically he's just going to back
and forth back and forth here I know it
feels like there should be away you know
but how how to do it
now we'll attack
okay how this is one of the most
incredible fortresses you can proudly
see because it's just the material
imbalance is huge I mean rook versus
Quinn it's not even a pawn
if this pawn wasn't here this is an easy
draw with a without a h-bomb but with
age planets yes Mike okay
can you sell and keep in mind you must
keep the pawn on f6 you push this
problem f6 forget it you'll lose
instantly like that you play check you
lose immediately in g4 now he's going to
go here and your king as soon as your
King appears on the background here like
this with seventh rank week you're going
to lose the game for example check guess
what sukh swung everybody know what is
sucks among when you don't have any good
moves to make basically so here your
King cannot move your pawn moves I come
up you go back here at checkmate you
that pun must remain if you if you ever
want to do a fortress with the rook and
a pawn versus a queen your pawn
remember your pawn must be on its
original square it's very important to
remember that because otherwise you
can't do much so I go here it really
it's a feeling is that there must be a
way to win this at least that's the
feeling but the question is can we find
anything concrete or this is a draw
after all
why not three
this is always a draw remember because
you can never clean the spawn you can
never clean this pawn the side pony can
never even if you have few of them we
can never quit so
Queen d4 King h7 King here I'm not sure
if I want to draw now hahaha mystery
well yes but not in the case where I can
forgive me now look whatever I say
remember that but sometimes keep your
options you know there will sometimes be
cases of course yeah in fact even if I
don't have f6 I will just cooking it I
have f6 but I go you you were trying to
get closer yeah but you can get closer
like this if you want
so absolutely incredible endgame here
with extra coin you are have you know
Mike any other ideas you were suggesting
something but but basically I'm just
going back and forth that's what I'm
trying to do but I have to make sure I
don't let you to push this pawn h6
that's what I have to make sure I have
to make sure you you can get there okay
because if you get that you're going to
win so I have to do it accurately like
Queen to e7 rook back
now I've take I just take back so if h6
I just go back it doesn't have a name
but it's just just one of the most
amazing fortresses in chess because it's
the imbalance is huge I mean without the
H pawn it's a common draw so this is a
draw everybody there is no way to win
this position strangely enough there is
no way to you know it's interesting if
you analyze this with the computer right
if we plug in a computer here engine it
will probably say what is winning you
know but after you know he's basically
going to go back and forth back and form
of the queen around and without making a
much progress if you don't if in this
position let's say this pawn is not
there okay like this position just keep
that in mind this this is the easy draw
okay here you don't have to do anything
basically you just simply go back and
forth back and forth okay and he can't
really make progress here because your
opponent's on the original square the
reason you have to keep it on a original
square because he doesn't have extra
rank to get behind your pawn if you push
this pawn on f6 so this is a draw
because you just like I say you just you
just go here back and forth he can't do
anything but let's say there is no way
to his King cannot cross that's what I'm
saying he can never cross the sixth rank
and if he cannot cross he cannot apply
more pressure on this so that's why you
can't do anything now what I wanted to
show you is remember I talked about this
pawn being here so much so I want to
kind of share with you why that's so
important okay so you'll have an idea
okay so now we have a position that
looks very much looks like very much
like the other fortress position but the
only thing is the pawn on f6 instead of
f7 who can tell me the difference here
why this is winning and the previous
position is drawn
what's the difference that you see here
aha Queen can go back to check excellent
excellent yes so Queen goes here check
when he goes here you actually have the
possibility of get behind it in the
other example there are no more no more
squares on the board you can't really
get behind it so he will try to give
couple of annoying checks but you just
play it accurately and he runs out of
checks
now it's getting more tricky now because
the way we're going to win this we're
going to have to force the skin to go
away from the pond first we're going to
win the pond and then I'm going to teach
you how to win that position but first
let's win the pond here so let's say he
sits here check now he goes here if he
goes away we go clean it so now you go
here
now he's tied up to this weakness what
to do you have to be very careful if you
move your rook away from the king their
chances of check and taking your rook so
you can't really afford to move the rook
anywhere you like so for example he sits
he does something like this 125 then you
want to go Queen fi check now
so it goes rook g5 now you can go check
check from here yeah we can check from
there - he's going to play a fire but
now he goes here guess what
now his kings in a mating net so he can
really do too much and if you had gone
here now we win the pawn check check and
we pick it up now how do we win this
position the question is because he can
go here it looks like we're so close you
know so close to the victory but still
we have to we have to win this you know
it's actually they're not easy to win
these positions if you don't know the
exact exact idea that you're looking for
here because you can play king f4 and it
feels like the victory is near he goes
check and you come up here in
expectation that you're going to make
now next move here no matter what you
see the drawing move
absolutely Okafor and guess what's still
mate again be very careful I've seen so
many people like you even you know at
the practice games and tournament they
just quickly play because keep in mind
likely you're not going to have too much
time left on a clock when you reach the
position like this because this is going
to be like move sixty or something so
you have to you know note the idea how
to win okay
so basically what you need to do in this
position so if you go here he is just
going to continuously check you so you
don't necessarily want to do that here
you can just play twenty seven you want
to move the King further away a little
bit so no more still mate ideas now if
you go sking g6 you get closer check
yeah
now you go check now you're getting
closer now you go check now if it goes
back you just go here this is the one so
it goes here now you need to remember
the idea that is called waiting move in
a position this is one of the critical
positions you're going to get so you
need to remember that waiting move idea
here so here all you need to do is pass
the turn to your opponent so you need to
move make a move that doesn't really
changes the concept of the position too
much which one is that
that it just keeps things the way they
are yes huh
when a one is good but let's keep it the
center area same idea but keep it in the
center you must control that diagonal
okay that's very important for you to do
that so this is the move Queen before
now if King goes back here again you
walk up okay so he goes check now goes
here and it goes King h8 it's amazing
this position has occurred before there
were a couple of incidents are very
strong world-class grandmasters top 10
top 15 players in the world to reach
this position they couldn't win because
they just never studied the idea and
happen twice at least two super
grandmasters couldn't win this position
so in order to win these positions you
have to know the concept here which
position you aiming for you're going to
get a position where he is in sook swung
basically any thoughts which position
we're aiming for it's quite amazing that
you need you have your queen on a
certain square huh okay
you need to have a plan you can't just
make moves well the problem is the king
is on the way so okay yeah we cannot win
the rook here so we're not aiming for
winning the rook here at the moment
you're going to win this different way
here yes
okay check and what's the winning line
because remember you go here I go check
you go here same idea
let's check oh you wanted yeah you can't
how you getting closer now you're
getting closer now actually but no no
you don't want to move the king your
king is an ideal spot here yeah but then
he checks you naturally you're very
close basically you want to reach that
same position you had but reach that way
so it's blocked to move okay so the
concept is the following you give a
check from this place and then you go
here this is the winning position
remember this is a winning position or
this is a winning position check check
or this is a winning position okay so
you have to memorize two positions King
on f6 Queen on h5 rook one g7 King on G
this is a winning position or same
position for the Kings
White Queen should be on e8 and they're
blocking on h7 that's this is a position
where now black is in souk swung
basically he needs to make a move and he
will he will lose his rook here no
matter what he does he's going to lose
his rook here basically let's look at
alternatives he goes here game is over
so he has to move the rook this is the
case where I mentioned if the rook goes
further away we check check check
even a windows so soon as he moves here
now you need to realize from where from
which two squares you can possibly check
and win the rook identify those two
squares
excellent job so this is the concept so
from here you can check and win the rook
okay so now let's achieve that the way
we achieve this is we give a cheque from
the central square first check because
he cannot go you always have to make
sure he cannot go to the background you
have a mate so it has to go here now
give two checks and window Rock one two
and the rook is gone yes Queen H one
cheque has to go back here you connect
the game is over okay so now let's look
at the other possibility if he goes so
you understand this one right look goes
on a seven check you go see a check and
you connect if he goes here sorry if it
goes here now now let's identify the two
other squares we're going to win the
rook from first you identify it then
it's a day you can just find a way to
get there which two squares you're going
to can check and win the rook when his
King is on hh7 same idea right h2 and a7
okay how we going to do that the way it
works is again you go to the central
square check now he can go to two
squares here or here so it goes here
now you want to give another check you
don't want to give a check from here
because if you go here he goes here and
then you don't have Queen h1 mate ok so
this would be inaccuracy you still win
but it's more complex so you go check
from here because now you can never go
here you have mate so he has to go back
to the back rank if it goes here you
give a check if you block themself nice
symmetry check mate
so it has to go back to g8 and now you
quickly connect via this check check
check
and guess what with the rock ok so
that's the only way you can basically
win if you have to know this position
where it's a souk salon okay so remember
two ways to do this okay
check not this way because this is rook
f6 so you have to try to go create check
this is a winning position same way you
win because you have to force his rook
to move away as soon as he moves away
you're going to be able to win it or you
can go clean a tribe I like this method
actually this way it seems like very
straightforward King on f6 Queen on h5
black rook on g7 King on Jade this is a
souk savant position he cannot do
anything ok so remember you need to have
a good plan to win this ok any questions
about rook and queen is you have to
still practice this but at least you
know what you're aiming for when you do
it ok yeah yeah yes you'll be able to
back them in a corner but you have to
know how to do the final touch and the
final touch is to reach this position
okay you should be able to back into the
corner with the use use of your king and
queen but be careful okay be careful of
that rook rook idea because I see it
quite often people think they already
want and quickly play here and then one
more mistake this is a common way black
and defend because otherwise it would
have been so easy to win this position
but this this problem is always there we
know when they check and they ready to
sacrifice the rook to win it alright
next position calculation okay this one
you need to calculate several moves will
still working on the fortresses white to
play and draw which move will draw this
game you basically need to calculate
formal search for moves here and by the
way if black had a bishop here instead
of a knight it would have been winning
easily but here we see a position where
Knight is much more inferior than a
bishop here white makes the correct move
and he is winning
because you will realize one more thing
so I'll give you a couple of minutes to
think about this
if the King comes out we need to resign
he will Queen the pond so if somehow the
King comes out it's all wash so you have
to calculate think calculate because
only one move will draw it yes is it as
simple as figuring out he has to be a
white square
for the next night movies gotta be in a
white square so the King s were not
really you might find a way to do the
squares but here is basically you need
to calculate where his night is going to
because he would need to use the night
to move your King away because you're
going to make a move that blocks him
right you know that if his King come out
you can you're not going to win this so
your movies obvious there - accounted
eight moves here you don't have like a
bunch of moves so you have only two
moves here so which one you go for you
you you basically have to be whenever he
gives you a check you need to go to f1
the light Square and then he doesn't
have a waiting move anymore okay so
that's how it works
so your first suggestion let's see why
this doesn't work if you go here he
comes up you got to stay here right to
keep him boxed in he comes up you go
here he goes 94 you see the scenario
your King cannot come here you got a
you're forced to go away and he Quinton
you resign but yeah
like you said square so you don't have
to do the calculation no no but you have
to calculate all right I mean yes yes
yes yes so so basically the concept is
right here but it's it see we're going
to mathematic a little bit here but yes
if the if if okay if I put the night on
the light square now where are you going
to go okay so basically I guess you have
to go to the light square you know you
have to yet you have to go to the if you
see a position like this you have to go
to the color of the square where the
night is that I want to be judged by the
night
yes okay so King f2 so he goes here now
here and the problem is when he goes
check you go back to a corner he can't
make a waiting move with a knight and he
can't really do any type of
triangulation with a knight to reach
this position okay but you have to
really calculate the four moves you have
to know that concept basically if the
knight is on the dark square your move
with the king should be on that dark
square if the knight is on the light
square so let's change that position now
so let's see the night is here
so now what's the move that will make it
make a draw here
I hope we're right this is see I didn't
notice but now this is finding out those
okay King f1 okay so he goes here yeah
yeah absolutely yeah so in a position
like this we have to go to the color or
the night if you're night is on the
light square we go on the lights go on
f1 if it's on a dark square anywhere on
the board we go to the dark square
that's how it works because yet this is
a this is a position I guess where you
can see the strength you know the
strength between a bishop and a knight
you know this is this is a position
where you see that strength you know the
bishop here would have been easily
winning here any color bishop you give
me a white square bishop sure King goes
on f2 he goes Bishop g2 resigns takes
away the squad kim jiwon he Quinn's okay
so let's change it to a dark square
bishop so you go King f1 checks the same
concept they check you go here with the
night it would have been a draw but the
with the bishop he's just waiting and
controlling that F 2 square so that's
why you see the bishop is stronger than
a knight that's why they say sometimes
Bishop is worth a little bit more three
and a quarter they say you know don't
that's I don't just come and exchange
your Bishop for no reason
whenever you exchange your Bishop for a
knight and you're going to give up two
bishops you must have a reason and make
sure in the end games you're
appreciating more okay this okay now the
next position I have continued on the
theme of fortress so you understand this
one okay
white to play and I'm sorry black to
white to play and draw can you find a
way to save this game questions very
tricky tricky calculate calculate I
don't want you to guess the move I want
you to actually find it you must
calculate five to six moves here to make
sure you have it because there are there
alternatives here you have there are
some alternatives if you do it but you
might not win even eetu yeah
looks like a draw huh how about this
all right okay the matter guess was each
mission
haha see your idea with the work and
less I had this brilliancy and if you
had gone here you remember this position
does this position look familiar to you
which position is this the very first
position remember that's a fortress you
just go back and forth with the king and
he cannot really make progress here
because King can I get closer to the
pawn okay
so unfortunately King G to the most
natural move here doesn't work this
makes your task a little bit easier
because you don't have too many options
here
excellent so that that's out oh
absolutely absolutely
now that's an excellent there but now
what's the way to draw this then okay
takes keep go on still not too late to
make a mistake and lose this game not
too late absolutely taking away squares
right so now you want to walk walk so
equals here
yeah one
but if you go f1 remember my pawn is
here not on h2 that's winning position I
just come up see this is this is winning
remember because my King is getting in
this is winning this is only a joy if
the pawn is on h2 so instead of going to
f1 you need to find a way to attack the
pawn so he pushes the pawn if he pushes
upon then it's a draw so the move is
king f3 now he's going to try to do
something he's gonna say have take my
knight take my knight he's going to say
not interested we were interested in the
pawn now he moves the knight on f2 we
take it so he goes here see if you if
you didn't know that this is a draw this
position you might sort of give up and
try to do something else but once now
you know this concept of the knight on
g4 Pollin h2 then you're going to think
about this ideas and the possibilities
that you have with the fortress so so
it's I encourage you to play until the
end in your games your practice games
your tournament games play until the
very end because you know you're always
going to be some chances look we saw a
position where the one player had a
queen versus rook equal amount of pause
that's to couldn't win it so they a lot
of lot of things that you still have
chances so you have to continue fighting
until the end only resign when it's just
completely clear that you have
absolutely no chances even if you have
1% chance I encourage you to play it on
because you're not playing against
grandmasters or you know professional
players at the moment so just just play
it on you'll get some chances today a
lesson sowhat's focus on fortresses the
possibilities of how to make a fortress
which fortress you can win and which
fortress you cannot break it we saw a
lot of positions will look like the
player with the material could win but
it wasn't easy also you saw the idea of
Queen and the rook versus king and rook
versus king and queen how to make a
drawing that one that that was very
important for you so remember that
position where your king is on f6 Queen
on e8 or queen on h5 his King is on g8
or g7 and that's the fortress that's a
position where you want them to be
that's a very important position for you
there are a lot of them there are so
many of them but what you saw today
these are pretty common fortress is
there a lot of lot of fortresses I would
say but this ones would use so today
this is the ones that are likely that
you can get in the tournaments